thanks to her roles in Bring It On All
or nothing and heroes Hayden Panettiere
became Typecast as an All-American
cheerleader but she endured her fair
share of trauma behind closed doors
despite her struggles she's racked up a
whole lot of personal achievements
when Hayden Panettiere was just five
years old she was cast as a main
character on One Life to Live although
pentatier's role did not have her
playing her own evil twin she managed to
exude cuteness and the doors to
Hollywood swung widely open in the years
that followed pinatier acted on One Life
to Live from 1994 to 1997 before leaving
the show to Star on another soap opera
Guiding Light in 2017 on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert pinetier recalled
her time on Guiding Light and the
adult-like crazy story lines involving
her character Lizzie Spalding they threw
me down well I got leukemia not once but
twice I was kidnapped when I shot my
mom's boyfriend all that sounds like
quite the heavy subject matter for an
actor not yet in middle school but
Panettiere can laugh about it now she
went on to say that Landing such a meaty
part at a young age gave her confidence
at 12 years old Hayden Panettiere joined
the Fox TV dramedy Ally McBeal a show
widely considered to be a groundbreaking
pop culture darling the series gave
birth to one of the first memes of the
internet the creepy dancing baby and
inspired water cooler conversations
Across America Ally McBeal showcases the
life of a deeply neurotic but lovable
Boston attorney and a diverse cast of
her co-workers and Friends starring
kalista Flockhart in the title role the
show ran from 1997 to 2002 and started
winning Awards as early as its debut
season for the final season of Ally
McBeal pinatier played Maddie Harrington
Ali's ten-year-old daughter Maddie was
conceived from eggs Ali donated to a
fertility clinic and shows up on her
biological mom's doorstep Panettiere
portrayed the character with a layered
emotional gamut that feels authentic for
a 10 year old embarking on a new
familial Journey although Ally McBeal
did not return for a sixth season
pinatier's short stint on the show
cemented her as a star on the rise
Hayden Panettiere's first Silver Screen
role came in the form of a small part in
1998 the object of My Affection starring
Jennifer Aniston and Paul Rudd however
it was her performance in the animated
film A Bug's Life released later that
year that truly allowed pennantiere to
shine the second Pixar film from John
Lasseter whom also helmed the ship of
Toy Story A Bug's Life had high
expectations to meet the film also had
The Misfortune of making its cinematic
debut six weeks after the eerily similar
ants on the bright side A Bug's Life
performed extremely well in home video
sales the nine-year-old Panettiere
starred alongside comedy a-listers like
Dennis Leary Dave Foley and Julia
Louis-Dreyfus pinatier voiced the
character dot an ant Princess and the
youngest daughter of Louis dreyfus's
Atta Queen of the ant colony dot hero
worships Foley's character flick and
longs to grow up due to her General
annoyance with her small stature
pinetier brought an endearing sweetness
to dot who learns to accept and embrace
herself quirks smallness and all
Hayden Panettiere didn't have to wait
long after A Bug's Life before landing
another part in a successful film in
2000 she was cast as Cheryl Yost in the
Stellar football film Remember the
Titans starring Denzel Washington based
on the true story of Hermann Boone the
first black head coach at Alexandria
City High School in Alexandria Virginia
Remember the Titans deals with the Deep
issues plaguing the post Jim Crow rural
south of the 1970s the inspirational
tale follows a high school football team
but digs far beneath the surface of
normal teen genre tropes Panettiere
played the daughter of the team's former
head coach Bill Yost who befriends
Herman after being demoted to assistant
coach he went a tough Camp from what I
can see
I'm very happy to have the approval of a
five-year-old although she was only 10
when she played Cheryl Yost Panettiere
had the chance to share the screen with
teenage up and comers like Kate Bosworth
and Ryan Gosling Bosworth told People
magazine that she felt like a big sister
to paint a Tierra while on set as for
Panettiere's thoughts on the film in
2020 she told the Washington Post they
used to show Remember the Titans in my
history class when they were teaching
about racism it always made me cringe to
be put on the spot like that but if I
had to choose any of the movies I've
been in to watch it would be Remember
the Titans
six years after Remember the Titans
Hayden Panettiere starred in the
football adjacent movie Bring It On All
or Nothing the third cheerleader comedy
in the series started by 2000's Bring It
On in the third offering pinatier played
the lead part of Brittany Allen a
teenage girl with it all in this
instance it all means she's a head
cheerleader with a hunky Star
Quarterback boyfriend but everything
changes when her dad loses his job
Brittany has to move from her cushy
all-white neighborhood to the less white
and cushy Crenshaw Heights where she
must find a way to fit in and
reluctantly tries out for the cheer
squad the film isn't of award-winning
caliber and received discouraging
reviews but Bring It On All or Nothing
proved that the 16 year old Panettiere
could carry a movie the actor added
layers to Brittany a role that certainly
could have come across as
one-dimensional during her stint in the
Bring It On franchise Panettiere played
a believable cheerleader audiences can
root for and pretty much laid a
foundation for her first career-defining
role save the Cheerleader Save the World
in 2006 Hayden Panettiere returned to
the small screen to play a different
cheerleader Claire Bennett on the NBC
hit Heroes the Tim Kring created
superhero drama turned out to be her
breakthrough performance the show
centers around Ordinary People Who
suddenly discover they possess
extraordinary abilities and according to
a mysterious prophecy the world's fate
hinges on Claire Bennett the role
allowed pennantier to show off her
acting chops but it also thrust her into
the Limelight of Hollywood Life pinetier
had to navigate through the public
scrutiny that comes hand in hand with
television success after a highly
praised first season the popularity of
Heroes waned as the storylines veered
off the tracks unfortunately the second
season of the show was shot during the
2007-2008 wga strike and the difference
in quality was immediately apparent
Kring even issued a public apology for
the show's changes nonetheless
Panettiere continued to shine in her
role the actress expressed a passion for
Heroes long after many fans had given up
as season 4 of Heroes was airing in 2009
she told Cinema Blend it's just exciting
and it's smart and I don't think it
belittles the audience ultimately Heroes
failed to recapture the magic of its
first season and was canceled in 2010
after its fourth season
after the cancellation of Heroes Hayden
Panettiere quickly moved back to the
Silver Screen following in the footsteps
of past teenage television stars like
Jennifer Love Hewitt and Nev Campbell
Panettiere took on the scream Queen
mantle she starred as Kirby Reed in the
fourth installment of the scream
franchise pentatier's character is best
friends with Sydney Prescott's cousin
giving her an indirect connection to the
story of the first movie that pans out
to be more significant as the plot of
Scream 4 unspools released in 2011
Scream 4 stands as the lowest grossing
film in the franchise earning just over
38 million dollars at the box office
however Kirby's survival skills made
Panettiere an instant fam favorite it's
a testament to Panettiere's portrayal
that she managed to win over fans with a
sense of loyalty to the original film
although Kirby's fate is left unclear at
the end of Scream 4 pinatier did reprise
her role in 2023's Scream 6. while
Scream 4 is technically considered a
commercial failure and a creative mixed
bag it obviously has its advocates
in 2009 Panettiere played another
cheerleader the title character in
director Chris Columbus's teenage comedy
I Love You Beth Cooper a story with more
than hints of John hughes's teen films
of the 1980s pentatier discussed the
film with cinema.com and was generous in
her praise of Columbus who's best known
for directing the 1990 Mega hit home
alone she said Chris Columbus is
incredible he's one of the nicest human
beings I've ever had the pleasure of
working with he's so talented and he has
no ego I hope this is not our last film
together however the critics were quick
to pan the film timeout called the
performances hammy and Slant Magazine
even gave I Love You Beth Cooper a half
star rating audiences weren't much
Kinder leaving scathing reviews on
Rotten Tomatoes the film flopped at the
box office earning just under 16.5
million dollars globally after the Beth
Cooper debacle and the cancellation of
Heroes Panettiere hung up her pom-poms
and moved on to other roles
in 2014 Hayden Panettiere gave birth to
a daughter Kaya of dokia Klitschko the
only child from her relationship with
Ukrainian national and heavyweight
champion boxer Vladimir Klitschko
Panettiere and Klitschko ended their
nine-year relationship in 2018 and their
daughter now lives with her father where
they reside in Ukraine until the
February 2022 Russian invasion the actor
still maintains a good relationship with
her daughter and shares co-parenting
responsibility with Klitschko but all
parties decided it was best for the
seven-year-old to spend some time with
her father after giving birth pinatier
struggled with severe postpartum
depression and decided to take her
experience public in 2015 People
magazine reported that Panettiere had
checked herself into a postpartum
treatment facility as she still dealt
with symptoms 10 months after giving
birth in the midst of her struggle with
postpartum depression pentateurs alcohol
and drug usage increased eventually
causing her to enter a treatment
facility in 2021 by sharing her own
experience panettier won to destigmatize
the condition for others she opened up
about her postpartum depression on Good
Morning America you know will women are
so resilient and that's the incredible
thing about them and and I think I'm all
the stronger for it
if Hayden Panettiere's role as Claire
Bennett on Heroes launched her into a
new level of Fame her turn as Juliet
Barnes in the Country Music epic
Nashville kept her there pentateurs
first fully grown-up role kept her
belting out tunes and playing out sudsy
traumatic storylines from 2012 to 2018.
the show spent its first four seasons on
ABC before it was canceled and ended its
run with 5th and sixth seasons on CMT
Nashville centers on the country pop
singer Juliet and her rise to the top
while often showcasing the bitter
rivalry between the up-and-coming star
and fading legendary singer Reina James
played by Connie Britton after a high
spoiler event at the end of season 5
Nashville lost its clear sense of
tension and met its second cancellation
not long after nevertheless Panettiere
proved her Talent went beyond acting by
singing her character's tracks on the
Series in 2012 Panettiere's single
telescope which is a Juliet Barnes track
on Nashville landed on the billboard
country music chart after Nashville
wrapped up in 2018
Panettiere took a break from acting she
didn't take a job in Hollywood from 2018
to 2022.
as Kirby Reed and Scream 4 Hayden
Panettiere faced down Ghostface and was
left to die when she was stabbed by the
killer Charlie after freeing him from
some misleading restraints a Dozen Years
Later the character of Kirby Reed is
back for 2023's Scream 6 thanks to a
contingency she requested that Kirby's
fate be left unstated when filming
scream 4. Kirby was always a
wisecracking character who had a love of
scary movies so she fits in well with
the Legacy characters of the franchise
and in Scream 6 she holds her own
against the barbs of none other than
Gail weathers played by Courtney Cox
herself Kirby barely survived her first
encounter with Ghostface telling Tara
she actually died for four minutes but
now she's in the FBI and says she takes
a particular interest in Ghostface cases
as with every scream film there are
misdirections and red herrings Galore
never making it easy to discern who the
actual killer or killers are it's one of
the franchise's core strengths as the
films have taken the horror genre as a
whole and turned it inside out going
meta on top of meta and Reinventing its
own tropes of course this means that
Kirby's actions are as Under Suspicion
as anyone else's and absolutely nothing
is off limits
if you or someone you know needs help
with mental health please contact the
crisis text line by texting home to
741-741 call the National Alliance on
Mental Illness helpline at
1-800-951-nami 6264 or visit the
National Institute of Mental Health
Website
thank you